we are here starting the show off right
with this year's host of the CMAs now
Smith and Billy Ray Cyrus of course and
Dallas is a four-time CCM a nominee
including Entertainer of the Year and
Billy Ray of course is just a country
legend on a scale of one to ten how
excited are you guys for tonight it's
off the charts I've been looking forward
to this for a long time I can't wait I
mean this guy's electric there's so much
talent that's taking the stage every
artist I just stood there with my jaw
dropped this one that it's incredible
the harmonies the songwriting on I'm
Billy Ray Cyrus from flatwoods Kentucky
I love country music and I love a great
country song and you're gonna get a
whole lot of that tonight and what I
love is I want the real real on how
rehearsal went yesterday I want the
inside scoop what was it like between
the two of you
this guy's automatic I mean all I gotta
do is hit my marker and he takes over
we'll see man we see how automatic he's
got a gift he's a very humble man and
that's that in itself is it it's
charming it's a special man he's got a
great charisma and a super talent and
celebrating his number one record drop
and I get to do it beside this guy so
not a bad deal yourself right pretty
incredible
Dallas you scored your eighth number-one
single with drop the most by any
Canadian country artist what does that
mean to you like means I keep getting to
do this I mean this is what I love I
love bringing songs to life from
bringing them up on stage making
connection with fans to me that's what
it's all about so that's what that means
means the industry is still supporting
me and I get to keep doing this so what
is the one thing that you've learned
about each other through rehearsals I
mean they don't give you a lot of time
but what are some things you've learned
about each other what I've learned about
him is his range as a vocalist and
listening again to him rehearse hearing
him sing with this band his band is
tremendous by the way your guitar player
matters unless it's out of this world
but his ranges of vocalist is just
incredible I mean there's nothing he
couldn't say thank you this has been
amazing I think we enjoy a couple
pastimes together I think we do some
stuff together but you know he's just a
very very very humble guy I've met a lot
of people that I've never I wish I
didn't meet you know I'm saying I get
you I don't I don't I I'm glad this
happened I got to need this we are all
very glad that it happened too so I know
you guys have to get in there thank you
so much for stopping by and have the
best time tonight